creation very exciting to see
everybody uh uh in real life
instead of those uh
surrounded by zoom boxes
um and welcome to the simons institute
i'm very glad we could we could host it
here
um we've had a change to the schedule
so uh sasha's talk sasha rucklin's talk
this afternoon uh we've had to cancel um
he's
on his way back to deal with a a family
matter um
so uh
unfortunately we will have a a gap in
the schedule there uh you know just
means we have a bit a bit more of a
break before the reception uh this
afternoon
i'm a reminder to wear your masks inside
uh and and you know the keep please keep
the food and uh
coffee outside and don't bring it into
the auditorium
um
okay and uh some introductions darren uh
is doing the
um
videography so you know he'll be setting
up speakers with microphones and
and hooking up computers and so on
and a big thank you to kalani penland
for all of uh her work in getting things
together thanks kevin
also thank you to um nike who uh
they hope is able to join us by zoom but
couldn't make it in person because of uh
teaching
uh so thanks thanks for all your work
nike uh
[Applause]
all right and i'll hand over to mission
okay so uh let's start the first session
with
fred kohler
giving a talk on uni from convergence
[Music]
okay is this working
okay it's working alright great
um
great thanks everyone for coming at 9am
on monday uh this talk is about
uh yeah uniform convergence
and so it's basically about
some attempts to understand how
generalization theory works
in the benign overfitting setting and
it's a joint work
with uh lija danica and notty
okay
and i thought since it's kind of like a
9am talk i'm gonna start off
maybe slow for some people i'm going to
go just remind you what's benign
overfitting
what does uniform conversions mean
but i think it might be a helpful
reminder and help get the notation set
okay so yeah literally started the
basics
so in this talk we're really going to
talk about learning with the
supervised and with a squared loss
so you are oops you have training data
which is sampled id from a distribution
and we're always going to label the
covariate or feature vector as x1 and
the label is y1
the goal is to find a predictor which
basically you can predict y-i from x-i
and they'll be measured
in terms of the error on a test sample
which is a fresh sample from the same
distribution
and you look at the expected error and
the square law so it's this is the
population loss functional
or the test loss
and of course uh and you know to try to
get a good predictor what you do is
minimize the training error
which is just the average squared error
over the data
okay
you know there's just a little fun
visualization you know here's a ground
truth curve
so in this case the distribution over x
is like uniform from zero to ten
samples like 10 training points
and then if you do empirical risk
minimization with a degree five
polynomial you get a curve like this and
you can kind of see that this is a
pretty good fit you know in the test
loss because it's kind of close to the
true curve on
most although not all of the
possible data points
and of course if we fit like a degree 17
polynomial well for one thing there's
more than one degree 17 polynomial that
goes through all the data points
um
and secondly we see that although it
gets a training error of zero
it has a very bad test loss so
it's clearly not close to the ground
truth curve
and
you know
this is a clear illustration of this
principle that models with zero training
error typically analyzed poorly
which you can find in any cisco learning
textbook
and then we have this whole theory of
uniform conversions which kind of
explain what is going on here
so you have the test there which is what
you care about you have the training air
which is what you minimize with erm
but then we also need to worry about the
generalization gap which is how
different those two could be
and uh basically you know if you go
through a textbook called physical
learning theory maybe the tldr is you
should pick a small class of functions
so that the second term is small the
generalization gap
and we have all these measures of
how big or small a class is like vc
dimension or rather macro complexity
and if you make that generalization gap
small then
you can kind of think that training
minimizing the training error makes
sense because it's close to the test
there which is what you actually care
about
and you know that's kind of uniform
convergence 101
and you know that's kind of a
foundational part of i guess statistical
learning theory
okay so that was
perhaps something that everyone knows
but anyway the nice thing about this is
it gives a very simple understanding of
what went wrong as an example
is that we simply fit two powerful class
the generalization gap is very big
which is why even though the training
area is very small the test area is very
big
okay and
yeah i think even this
okay there's been
i know a lot of people are very familiar
with this but just as a reminder
uh you know this is a plot from a paper
by misha velken and others and
you know what we see is that uh for some
machine learning models this is a fully
connected neural network on mnist
actually what happens is that the
training error which is the orange curve
gets very small and then the test error
is actually pretty good so
among other things you see that it's not
the story before because the training
air and test error are not close so the
class is not very small
of course there's also this famous shape
the double descent curve where you know
the test error goes down and then up and
then goes down
we're not going to be super concerned
with that shape because we're really
only going to look at the right hand
side of this plot
um
okay but so that that's a you know
definitely an interesting empirical
phenomenon that the
you know you can get this behavior where
getting the training error to zero even
with noisy data
can be a good way to minimize the test
loss
and this is another
slide from the same talk by misha at the
at the simon institute two years ago
uh and you know you can kind of get this
kind of behavior even if you add noise
to the labels so
you know in classical physical learning
theory if there is no noise in the model
then it makes sense uh to
find a perfect interpolator but
generally speaking you would think it's
a bad idea if there's noise but and yet
nevertheless it can work in practice
okay
and so the rest of this talk is going to
be about this model discussion linear
regression
which i guess is one of the most popular
theoretical models to try to understand
this phenomenon
that's a maybe incomplete list of all
the works considering this model of
course there's other models like kernel
learning
or different classification models where
people also study and observe double
descent
but maybe this is the most popular one
to study
and i guess that has
you know has some connections to kernel
learning obviously
and so formally the model we're going to
sample covariates from a gaussian
distribution with the arbitrary
covariance
and the response is a linear function of
the
covariate so
y i is w star dot x i plus noise
and we're always going to have a
positive amount of noise
so we're not in the classical setting
with no noise where it makes sense to
interpolate
and sometimes i'll use a matrix notation
so
you know this is also just conventional
notation for linear regression
you put the data into the rows of matrix
x and then the response is this vector y
which is x w star plus the noise
and just like before
the ultimate goal is to minimize the
test error on a first sample
okay and then with this notation the
interpolation is just when y is equal to
xw
since the triangular is
zero and the phenomena of a nine
overfitting it does happen in this model
and so in many cases if you look at the
minimum norm l2 norm interpolator
you'll find that the population loss
goes to sigma squared so or it's close
to sigma squared which is the optimal
and
there are some conditions which
essentially characterize when this
happened which are due to bartlett at
all but
so i'll get back to those conditions
later but for now we need to know is
that this is a model where
benign overfitting certainly can and
does happen
okay
and uh okay so what happens now we go
back to the uniform conversion story and
we can try to understand what's going on
so we can try to upgrade the test error
by the train air plus generalization gap
okay so what is the test error it's
sigma squared so that's like
when benign overfitting is happening
then the test error is sigma squared
the training error is zero and so we in
order to prove the optimal bound on the
test error we need that the
generalization gap should be like sigma
squared right
um
okay and just a reminder so here i
change notation a bit but here k is the
class so it's a collection of simple
hypotheses
containing w so and in particular you
would normally look at the set of low
norm predictors
and then the issue with this is it
actually just doesn't work and so this
is kind of considered a failure of
uniform convergence
and what happens is just that you can
compute the generalization gap over
for example the class of low norm
predictors and
if you pick a norm that's big enough to
contain the interpolators then the
generalization gap is much larger than
sigma squared
so i think more precisely what's shown
in these works is that
for example if you look at the l2 ball
and you look at what's the absolute
value you get something that's like
infinitely larger than sigma squared
which is really bad
yeah okay then you can think well we
only need an upper bound so you can
remove the absolute value
even then you'll get something larger
than sigma squared although it's much
better but uh still it's too large
okay
um
yeah and i guess also you can just plug
in all of your favorite generalization
bounds for
linear regression and they all have this
kind of problem because they're trying
to control
even if they're not literally of this
form they generally speaking don't work
and so there's again another aside from
misha's talk
and you know it's just kind of
summarizing the situation which is that
all those symbolization bounds
they don't really seem to work for the
situation and it's because
you upper bound the test loss by the
training loss plus a bound
but then the bound usually has some
large constant factors and so on in it
so you get an upper bound which is often
trivial or
not really informative at all about the
test loss
and this is kind of part of uh you know
there's been lots of papers discussing
related issues to this
and pointing out that when you plug in
generalization valves they just don't
work in this situation
and with varying levels of like maybe
optimism and pessimism so i think
i mean because the generalization don't
seem to be working people have kind of
suggested that maybe the uniform
convergence theory is a little bit
obsolete um at least for understanding
this kind of big models with uh small
training gear
and of course yeah other alternative
messages have been proposed to study
this
okay so because the generalization
theory doesn't seem to be working
what you can do at least in the linear
regression case is study is a closed
form i mean you can study the empirical
risk minimizer using its closed form
solution which is a pseudo-inverse
and based on that okay it's good because
you can theoretically understand what is
going on so you can prove that even
though all the sterilization violence
didn't work
uh you can recover the the correct
behavior you know that
the minimum norm interpolator is in fact
consistent um
and so i guess that's kind of a success
right so you can go ahead
uh yeah i guess i'm being a little bit
vague so
and in general you can consider that
there's a sequence of covariance
matrices and they satisfy certain
conditions
and so the sequence of covariance
matrices they're growing with
the number of samples n
and the bartlett at all results
basically give you essentially a
characterization of
what properties that sequence of
covariance matrices need to have such
that the
minimum normal interpolator is going to
converge in population loss through
sigma squared so that's
it's a sequence of population
covariances yeah so that in probability
you will converse with sigma squared
right
yeah so this particular like
can you say something about consistency
for a
fixed problem like a fixed population
well like if you have a because you need
to change the covariance with the number
of samples because
sorry we're always in the over
parameterized regime right so if i grow
the number of samples i can't keep the
covariance fixed
because the covariance is like d by d
and d needs to be bigger than n so you
always need to have a sequence of
coherence matrices
yeah you could consider a kernel setting
um
yeah that's right so people also studied
kernel learning
at least in this gaussian linear
regression model you'll need to keep
changing the size of sigma
oh you could yes okay you can have an
infinite that's true yeah andrei is
right yeah you can have an infinite
covariance matrix and that's also yeah
discussed in
our little favor and you can write down
the conditions for
an infinite uh covariance matrix with
the right properties
i think there is something where like
maybe if you look at a sequence of
covariance matrices you can get more
like it's
you can sort of get more general
conditions yeah that's right so you can
also write down conditions for an
infinite one
um but maybe it's better to look at us
yeah
yeah yeah i guess uh you know there are
a lot of experts in the room so please
feel free to comment uh or
raise questions
okay so that's that's great and so why
am i
doing this talk if we kind of understand
what's going on in this model
well there are things we don't
understand so you can see we don't
understand what's going on with the
generalization bounds except that maybe
they don't work
and arguably i would say that there's
kind of a philosophical question which
hasn't been answered
and so it's philosophy because it's not
really a concrete question but
arguably this analysis although it
proves that the closed form um it proves
that the minimum norm interpolator works
it doesn't necessarily answer the
question of why we picked the minimum
normal interpolator
so we have lots of different
interpolators and
the minimum normal triple later
we might think it is the simplest one
because that's the smallest norm
but in the analysis norm does not really
play a
role in particularly there's no direct
link made between the norm of a
predictor and its set error which is
what a classical generalization bound
would do
and so it's uh that that part is yeah
not entirely made clear by the existing
analysis
yeah what the norm has to do with the
test error
okay
and so it leaves us with this question
whether the conventional generalization
theory could explain
benign overfitting at least in this
model
okay and what we're going to do is we're
going to consider sort of a plan of
attack which was outlined by zhao at all
in this 2020 paper and
what they do is they say okay well
uniform convergence it could mean many
things
we need to be careful about what we're
saying by uniform convergence and really
what we should look at is the worst case
air among interpolators so it's a kind
of a localized version of uniform
convergence
where you put in the constraint not only
as a predictor in this set but also that
the training area is small
so you can visualize it this way
there's predictors which have low norm
and there's a smaller set of predictors
which have low norm and low training
here
okay
we're going to take it to be big enough
that it contains the minimum solution
yeah not not to be exactly exempt of
normal solution but
yeah a little bit bigger yeah but that
isn't this a little bit uh
obviously
it's obvious that if you pick exactly
the minimum norm that you're over
but the of the new number
will concentrate right so it does
concentrate
right right so okay um like one thing
that's going to happen is like something
that's maybe not obvious is that if you
multiply as a norm by like one plus
epsilon
how does the test loss change and then
we're going to be able to understand
that so even if
you know you don't literally get the
minimum norm but like you're a multiple
approximation you still have a very good
generalization guarantee yeah that's a
good question
it's a minimum
yeah so the minimum norm is data
dependent so here we're thinking b is
like because the norm concentrates b
would be like a high probability upper
bound yeah you can know that like if you
have um
yeah like if you like oh obviously if
you have all the founders of problem you
all know that
uh you can also get a upper bound on
that which don't require to know all the
parameters of the problem but
and i i guess at the very end like i'll
also talk about a bound which
would not even need to have a priori
knowledge of b like you could plug in
the actual norm but
i guess conceptually you can almost
think you know you can union mount over
all the b's
and since that's just a one parameter
dimensional family that shouldn't be too
expensive
and um
yeah so this is a this is uniform
convergence not exactly of the form that
i started out with in the first slide
but it is a kind of unique form
convergence which has been studied for a
long time in learning theory
and so for example this is from a
textbook by deroy giorphy and lugosi
and you can see here what they're doing
is they're analyzing
the generalization error of a zero
zero training error predictor
the thing that is a bit different from
our setting is that they are assuming
that there is no noise in the model so
uh
you know it will correspond i mean
they're in a classification setting and
they assume that there's no noise so
it's not the same setting but they are
using the same kind of bound which we
would call uniform convergence of
interpolators
and so this is a classical notion of
uniform convergence
okay and so anyway here's the conjecture
from zhao at all the conjecture is that
you have a very sort of straightforward
kind of generalization bound which is
the test loss is upper bounded by the
norm squared
times basically the expected size of the
covariates squared divided by n
so that's very similar to what you see
in conventional generalization bounds
except that um there's no leading
constant factors and
you know because uh if i double the
right hand side
you know if the right hand side is sigma
squared and i double it i would get two
sigma squared which is very bad
so it is a very important part of this
conjecture that it doesn't have a
leading constant factor
and you can sort of think this would
answer our philosophical question
because it would show that
actually there is a meaningful relation
between
the amount of norm you need to
interpolate the data and test error and
in particular it's good to minimize
the amount of norm because that is upper
bound on the test error so that would
sort of create a link between norm and
test error which we don't have
um but when they made it it's
yeah go ahead
so here uh
yeah i'm gonna be a little more formal
later yeah
so the conjecture like has the state of
like a little bit i don't know if not he
wants to say but like
maybe it's better to write one plus
little one times the other thing that
would be
yeah but this doesn't say that there's
no factor norm you have another upper
bound which is better
yeah that's right so this this upper
bound might not always be tight yeah but
we're going to show that it's tight
enough to explain a lot of things
so does
yeah so the little one everything you
know can can be made into like actual
error terms then you won't have to worry
about that
or you could consider like some kind of
sequence of matrices yeah but
um basically the little one term is
actually going to be things that are
much smaller than
this term which is going to be very
large yeah
so this is uh for interpolating
classifiers with the same thing calls if
you're in the superpower
uh yeah so this bound is only for um
interpolators yeah so
that's right so the the form of the
bound i think i'll get back to this
maybe at the end of the talk about how
you would state a bound like this or
also for the classical regime yeah but
uh
right now this conjecture is only for
interpolation so it's only on the right
of the double descent
um
yep
i stated it just holds for any b and any
n
yeah but you have to be able to
interpolate the data
yeah like i think well if you put the
construct
if you put the love double zero
you know i understand
maybe something similar
it is something similar to this
okay um so i just wanted to say yeah um
yeah i guess in the collaboration
meeting in
uh last year lisa talked about this work
and um
what they did in that work is not only
of course just state the conjecture but
they proved it in a certain case which
is
called a junk features model um it's
basically a specific model of the
covariance
yeah i guess i won't describe exactly
what it is so they prove it in that
model but the proof doesn't apply to a
general covariance
and also in a later work by yang bai and
mei um they also studied uniform
convergence with interpolators
and they showed um
something of this flavor
happens in a certain random features
model uh
so there's the main prior works on
uniform convergence of interpolators
and what we're going to do in this paper
um
is prove the conjecture in the general
setting of the gaussian linear
regression model that i described
we're going to prove this inequality and
also we're going to show not just that
this inequality is true
but that it's explanatory
so you can show how to recover it's a
benign overfitting conditions um from
partly at all
and you can also get some new results
which generalize uh
beyond you know just the l2 uh norm uh
minimum l2 norm interpolator so that's
that's what we're going to talk about
okay
so this is uh generalization bound um
yeah i i guess i wrote this with the
little one a little and
um in the paper there are the
finite you know finite sample downs um
in terms of quantities which are
generally speaking small so
yeah i can answer questions about
exactly what the little one means but
essentially this is what the balance
says
it says
i'm going to look at a class so
the way this model is set up the class
is just a subset of rd
i'm going to look at the gaussian waves
of the class which of course is a
natural measure of the complexity
i'm going to talk about that a bit more
on the next slide
and what you get is that the
test loss of interpolators and the class
k
is upper bounded by the gaussian width
squared divided by n
and in this gaussian width
you know there's a sigma to the one half
so that expresses
well you can either think that in the
definition of gaussian lists we're
actually sampling h from normal zero
sigma that's totally equivalent
or you can you know you can just take
the set and multiply every point in the
set by sigma to the one half and it's
the same so
either way you look at it it's a
gaussian with square divided by n
okay and this is going to recover as a
conjecture that i stated before
i wanted to say the gaussian width um
okay maybe people are more familiar with
rademacher complexity these are very
similar concepts
in fact in our example they're actually
equal okay so
random macro complexity measures how
well functions in a class
can correlate with pure noise in the
form of random signs you know this is
maybe the textbook notion that you see
uh in a
you know textbook on learning theory
and we can compute the so-called the
expected random macro complexity is
averaged over the
data
of the class of linear predictors where
the predictor is in a set k
and so this is the definition of the
radical complexity i average over these
random signs sigma
and over the
covariates x
and i look at the sub premium over the
class of the basically the dot product
of the function with
the random signs so now okay here the
class is linear functions
and i said k
so i can just plug in the definition of
the class this is equivalent i guess i
use like linearity
this is just the same thing where i
plugged in the definition of the class
basically
and i split the 1 over n into 1 over
squared and 1 over squared n
and now what you see is like
this 1 over square root n sum of the
random signs times the x i's
well that actually can be simplified a
lot right because that's you know if i
take a gaussian and i multiply by a
random sign it's still a gaussian and i
might take a bunch of independent
gaussians and average them appropriately
i just get a gaussian with the same
covariance distribution
so that expectation can be simplified
into expectation over just one gaussian
the gaussian has covariance sigma so
this is the gaussian width of sigma to
the one half k um
and yeah because there's a one over
squared n factor
uh i guess it differs by that scaling
factor but otherwise these are exactly
the same concept in in the case of
gaussian linear regression
okay
and so if you like you can state the
generalization bound this way
it says that the test loss is upper
bounded by the rademacher complexity
square of the class
unlike conventional generalization
bounds maybe
you know it's not for an arbitrary
distribution of x but it is of like
totally the same form in the sense that
it
overbound the generalization error by a
complexity measure of the class
yeah
yeah yeah so it's a small one
i think for this setup
yeah yeah
so the smaller one includes something
like
a one over square root n term
so that like squared log
so yeah you know there's a multiple so
it's not literally one but it's like one
plus a constant times square root log
two over delta over n so that's that's
in the little of one
there are also some small additive terms
so because at some point we use gaussian
concentration over the class
there's something like the radius of the
set divided by square root n and that's
that's those are the little one terms
and that's that's an additive term and
okay yeah sorry there's okay there's a
a more general way to state this sorry
i've been kind of skipping over this
like to really get the full bartlett at
all results you need to integrate this
notion of a covariance split um
which makes the sound a little more
complicated so
uh i was for most of the talk i was
planning to just kind of admit that
detail
but if you put that back in um
you can replace like what i said is true
but you can actually replace this
gaussian with by a generally smaller
gaussian width where you replace sigma
by this sigma 2
and then you'll get the radius of
sigma 2 one-half times k
yeah so
there there's a bunch of those things so
that's pretty much it so basically
there's a molecular factor of like
squared log over one
log failure probability over n and then
there's an additive term which comes
from the radius of the set and that's
basically it yeah
sorry
because i'm
yeah yeah yeah that's right so
okay maybe i can
right with this marker so more generally
um like the more general
general bound looks like
so
you would get something like square root
rank
1
log
2 or delta
divided by n
uh times the gaussian width
of the class squared divided by n
plus something like uh
i forget exactly what it is but it's
something like
it's possible that's squared or
something but that's that's basically
like the
for people who like to seize a precise
uh generalization around it's it's
something like this and there should
also be like a confidence term here
okay um so
uh this is multiplied by this uh so this
is
this is one part of the finite sample
bound
so
and here i'm assuming sigma is
1 and sigma 2 0 0.
so you can make the bound a little more
accurate by yeah basically adding this
kind of split feature into it
and then in this split in this term you
have the rank of sigma one so you don't
want to make sigma one too big
um
yeah so that's really more of the the
full gnarly details of the bound
oh sorry this is
l of w
yeah yeah this is true without doing all
the splits the split just makes it
tighter but
does it
yeah so i'm gonna explain in these
slides i have like a free sketch of this
bound and you have to do a bunch more
work to get this foot down yeah so the
split has to do with like
this is kind of like a non-localized
sound in some sense and the split lets
you do some kind of localization so
they're related but the split is more
complicated
don't forget about the police or
anything
a few number of dimensions using
dimensionality
irrespective of the scale and the rest
using the scale
so this is the split yes it's a split
yeah it's like this effective dimension
notion right so
like in uh i guess in kernel learning
there's like some work by tong jiang and
others um
where it's like if you want to get a an
optimized bound for kernel regression
like looking at um
basically the norm of the data is not
quite the optimal saying you should take
into account the eigenvalue structure of
the kernel matrix and basically you can
hand like large a few large eigenvalues
of the kernel matrix don't cost you that
much in generalization so that it's
actually like a classical thing that
that shows up in in benign overfitting
too
all right so that's going to show up too
because
we still need to calculate the norm of
the minimum norm interpolator and
that that that that's like this maybe
you know he has three conditions and
like that's the third condition that
will show up there yeah
but the generalization value is just
always true it's just sometimes the norm
is big
and so like i said this will recover
the conjecture because you can just
compute the gaussian width of the l2
ball and uh
since this is this is also the
rademacher complexity so if you think
about it
you might be familiar with this
calculation already from looking at
rademacher complexity
okay so we recovered that conjecture
and i'm going to
talk a bit now a bit more later about
why this explains
the consistency of the nine over fitting
um and last like we were saying
this has some benefit because it tells
you not just that the minimum normal
interpolator would generalize well but
as long as you can kind of get a low
norm interpolator it has a good
generalization guarantee as well
to use this there's some dependency on
the sigma
so b you're gonna like this bound is
always true but if you pick b that's too
small there's no interpolators so it's
not a very interesting amount so like to
show consistency we want to show that
that the loss can register
yeah exactly so we'll need to upper
boundary and uh i'll talk about that
so okay these are the nine over fitting
conditions which
we've been talking about and uh yeah the
first two are basically standard and
kernel learning i think um
and the third one is is
very important for going over fitting
i'm not going to go into too much and
what it means but
it lets you yeah fit the noise without
um very efficiently
and later yeah if we have time i'll go
into
the proof of this using our technology
which would make clear
why those conditions would naturally
show up
anyway um
yeah what we show
under these conditions the benign
overfitting conditions
you can prove a upper bound on the norm
of the minimum norm interpolator
and
you know okay it might look a little
weird
it's exactly the thing that's going to
cancel out the other terms in the
generalization bound when you plug it in
so
and so
that that's i guess among other things
telling you that this bound is actually
useful like so it's tight enough to
explain the nine overfitting
um of course i didn't tell you how we
proved the norm but i'll get to that
later okay
and
i thought i'll just include like a fun
plot
so this you know you can also just
if you didn't want to analytically
compute the norm you could try to just
empirically completed a bunch of
examples this is just some example
uh where benign overfitting happens um
you have a covariance with
one large eigenvalue and many small
eigenvalues
uh the blue curve is a test loss and the
orange curve is the what you get just by
plugging into the generalization value
um
and so the nine overfitting situations
you can kind of see
as i'm increasing the dimension so the
number of very small features
you know the test loss is getting close
to the base error or like sigma squared
the minimal air
and you can see that this boundary is
capturing that so this is kind of a
visualization of what i was saying in
the previous slide that the bound is
tight enough to understand the nine over
consistency of the nylon fitting
okay
the band is because the norm has a bunch
of variants yeah so
asymptotically uh if you
if you are in the like n to infinity
limit that variance doesn't matter
um but yeah and that's why we have all
these confidence terms in the
bound because the the norm does vary and
i'm plugging in the bound with the norm
of the actual data
i guess if i use the high probability
bound on
the norm it wouldn't have so much
variance and it will it would just be
bigger but it will look essentially the
same
yeah so it is that that's what the band
means it's the standard deviation
okay
uh yeah let me briefly say you know i'm
not going to go into the details about
this because we have a gaussian with
bound you can plug in for other
geometries
and you know one of our favorite norms
the size l2 norm is l1 norm which we use
like in lasso
and adaboost compressed sensing
and people were asking what goes on with
the l1 normal and analyzing this
and
what you can show is that in the junk
features model which kind of looks like
this it's a covariance with like i said
identity
and many very small
eigenvalues
you can use our technology to prove that
the minimum l1 norm interpolator is
consistent in
it with this kind of covariance
structure
and uh we also yeah generalize the
benign overfitting conditions so
you know we have some general conditions
um for a general norm and just
specializing it in this example shows
that the minimum l1 norm interpolator is
consistent in this setting
and i think this is a terminology was
the first time that
has proved l1 norm minimum norm
interpolation
is consistent um
you know it's not so easy to analyze
directly because the
like the basis for solution doesn't
really have a nice closed form like the
like the resolution does
okay
yep
okay like it works for everyone i should
mention that um you need a very large
number of features for this to work and
i think there are some later some
follow-up results showing that it's
it's kind of tight so like you need like
so many features um
at least in this specific model for it
to work that it's hard to get it to show
up in a simulation so the l2 norm is a
lot better i think in that sense for
benign overfitting
all right yeah i'm not sure they answer
your question
i mean what about l3 or something else
yeah our crm works for any norm but we
only try to visit l1 yeah i think you
with this kind of junk feature model
it's a good question which i
haven't thought about i think it should
work also for other norms
as long as you take a lot of features
but not one
yeah
can you say something about the rates of
convergence to the consistency oh yes
like i was saying yes the radio
convergence is this example is extremely
slow like
yeah it's like
do you need a like
for n samples so you need like a number
of features at least based on our
analysis which is exponential in the
number of examples that was it
okay and in this paper by do it all um
they have
some kind of lower balance saying that
the rate of convergence has to be
extremely small so
both l1 2 do you know which fights slow
but we try slower
yeah l2 is pretty fast
like like you know all these bounds like
the convergence is like one or fourth
root of n or one over square root of n
but where l one is like one over square
root of volume so that's uh
that's it
yeah there's there's no conversion
straight issue for zelda
so i thought
yeah i'll try to explain it's a proof
idea i think actually one benefit of
this analysis is that
well i don't know like
this is not you know extremely simple
but i think it's it's not extremely
complicated either and
hopefully i can convince you of this
so i think
it kind of shows uniform convergence is
uh can be helpful even if you just want
to get the answer
okay so anyway the key thing
um is we're going to do
the generalization gap is a random
optimization problem
so
what does it mean generalization gap
we're going to look at this class of
interpolators in the set 8
and we're just going to find the thing
that has the worst test loss so that's
that's the optimization um
with lagrange multipliers you know i can
write it as a maximum optimization
and then as i imagine many people are
familiar with there are really good
tools for analyzing
random optimization with gaussian data
in particular there's this result called
gordon's serum
um
which has like a huge number of
applications
and like compress sensing and
high-dimensional statistics
so anyway
basically gordon's theorem says if i
have a max min problem like this
then it involves a random matrix but it
can be upper bounded uh with high
probability
by an optimization which just has random
vectors so gaussian random vector g
okay so
and coordinates is exactly just like a
recipe that tells you how to convert
the random matrix problem to
the random vector problem
uh so you get this so there's um
like basically what happened is
originally there's this interaction
between the lambda and w star minus w
and this random matrix x
but now you get these two terms where
it's a laser pointer
don't worry about that
you get these two terms whereas the
interaction between
the lagrange multiplier lambda and
the predictor w becomes much simpler so
the lambda is now just a dot dot product
with a random gaussian vector
and the
interaction with w is just continuous in
this norm term
and then you have an additional term
which is similar which is like
symmetrical
and
so the sort of it is that theorem
automatically converts the first problem
to the second problem
um
now you can sort of explicitly solve for
what's going on in that problem so i
just write the problem again
i can make a nice substitution um so you
got this optimization problem
okay and now like the great thing is
there's a min over lambda but you can
kind of think
you can kind of just solve this
explicitly because either
the min player can pick a really big
lambda and take
this loss to negative infinity um
which is the case
uh basically if the first term with
lambda is bigger than the second term
with lambda
or they can't do that and the best thing
they can do is zero
and so just formalizing that you get uh
basically just applying the branch
multipliers out of the way
you get that it's a
maximization over all the vectors in the
set which satisfy some inequality so
and then that inequality is just saying
the first term is upper bounded by the
second term
and then
okay so this has a norm of a g times u
plus the noise c but g and e are both
gaussian random vectors
and they're independent so they're very
in high dimensions you know those are
almost exactly orthogonal so you can
just use like pythagorean theorem to
uh to simplify that constraint and
you'll get this u squared plus sigma
squared which is almost h dot u squared
over n
okay and then it seems kind of magical
because now you are trying to maximize
and the constraint is exactly telling
you an upper bound on
the optimum
so you get this inequality
that
this thing you care about is upper
bounded by is a maximum of this dot
product squared
and that is essentially the definition
of the gaussian weights squared
so that that's basically the proof
sketch of the main theorem
um
yeah when you make it formal there's a
bunch of technical details
the covariance splitting is actually a
little bit important to get all the
concentration
uh inequalities to work out
but that's essentially the calculation
okay
and yeah you have to do a more
complicated argument for the coherence
but uh
you know it's not wildly different
okay um sorry i thought i'll briefly
show this storm bouncing so these are
uh just to avoid having to talk about
this covariance with all the time this
would be like a simpler
benign overfitting conditions which are
not as general but don't have a
coherence split
so basically the norm of the data cannot
be too big and you still have this
condition that there's some kind of
some kind of large effective dimension
condition which is key to enabling
banana overfitting
and um you want to show some kind of
upper bound on
the norm of the minimum normal
interpolator and you want to show
something like this okay i wrote it a
bit differently so there's a w star on
the right hand side that's actually
as small compared to the last term so
it's the same
as what i wrote before but
anyway if you have that uh then you can
plug it in
to the generalization bound and like i
was saying before you get the sigma
squared plus lower order terms
and
you can already see
if i phrase it this way why we have the
first condition
is that the norm of w hat squared in
particular has the number of w star
squared in it
and the first condition is just telling
you that
uh if i plug in w star squared um
that
uh that the term on the right hand side
is little of one
the it already makes clear why we have
the first condition which is kind of the
standard condition
then
to understand where the second condition
comes from uh you can just do a similar
kind of analysis where you compute the
minimum form
but nice thing is that because of the
way our framework works you just need to
upper bound the minimum norm which
actually makes i think the calculation a
lot easier than if you needed to compute
it um
well it makes you know you can use
inequalities right so that's very
convenient
so
yeah first of all you can use triangle
inequality to get rid of the wsr term
so you just need to find the minimum
norm interpolator in a setting where
there is no signal
then using gaussian comparison like
before uh you reduce to some
optimization with a constraint so this
is totally analogous to before
now to solve this optimization uh it's
not actually clear how to solve it from
here
but you can just kind of make a guess
for what the minimum might look like so
there's a dot product
so maybe easy optimum will uh you know
be along the direction of the vector
similar to the one half h
seems like a reasonable guess
then you plug it in and just kind of you
can automatically solve it the
constraint now gives you uh
it tells you how small you can take um
basically the norm of this interpolator
w
and so just kind of
automatically doing it out you get
sorry about that you get this okay um
and now sort of magically the second the
nano repeating condition comes in
because this expression is actually very
close to what we want but there's this
minus sigma h squared in the denominator
and then
when you interpret everything in terms
of traces of the covariance
uh the the nine overfitting condition
exactly means that you can ignore
this complicated
minus sigma a squared term
and yeah again interpreting everything
in terms of traces of sigma so the norms
squared is the threes of sigma
the norm of sigma h squared is like the
trace of sigma squared
uh you exactly get
the the thing we need which is sigma
squared and divided by the expected form
so
now i'm going to be quickly over that
the
you know it's just application of convex
gaussian min max theorem and
all the conditions appear kind of
transparent
and actually the
proof for the minimum normal
interpolator is actually this is
essentially the same proof
with the coherence today
the covariance splitting only really
complicates the proton generalization
okay
um
[Music]
okay so i have a few slides after this
quickly but
specifically
what did we show
well we showed that uniform convergence
could explain that overfitting
which brings up the question is why did
we care
okay and so this i guess is the main
justification that i was suggesting at
the beginning
is showing that you know maybe 40 years
of statistical learning theory could
still be relevant to modern practice in
ml
and it's not necessarily the case that
it's obsolete the uniform conversions
theory
um we kind of saw that like okay in
situations where direct analysis is
difficult like the one norm
interpolation
uh uniform convergence uh let us get the
answer as to what's going on there
and finally we saw that
you know
and sometimes we got a more modular
explanation of why the generalization
that happened
um you know we saw that this third
banana repeating condition it shows up
exactly and
when we ask for is a predictor to have a
low norm and also we know that
just not knowing anything like that if
the norm of the interpolator is small
then you should generate as well which
we didn't know before
and finally since this is uh
i guess deep learning theory
um
you know
all those things might make this
approach a little bit more scalable like
since we're not relying on the exact
form of solution
um
if we could first understand the
implicit bias of optimization algorithms
for deep networks and the second proved
a similar squared uniform convergence
bound maybe we could understand why it's
a device
and of course it could be applied to
other models
not just c numbers
okay so in a few minutes i think i have
a few minutes now right
now because i don't want to say since it
came out before like how does a theory
extend to the case where
it's not just like the
the very over parampara setting but also
can
capture as a conventional setting or
maybe you have less parameters
than samples and there's no
interpolators
yeah and so of course the conventional
generalization balance would apply in
that case but they don't really work
they're too loose
and the uniform convergence of
interpolators only seems to work when
the training error is exactly zero
so what do we do well one thing we could
do is we could open this textbook by
rapnic
from 1982 and we can kind of see okay
just like there was uniform convergence
of interpolators in this textbook
there is also some kind of
generalization which
has to do with the case where the
training error is not zero and so this
theorem is in like a totally different
notation and it's in a classification
setting
but what it says that the the test error
is upper bounded by the train air and
this is the generalization gap
and the thing is um you know very
you know the very important thing in
this tech in the context of uh yeah and
then in the context of the original
theorem is that when the training area
is zero the generalization gap is much
smaller
than when the training area is big
and another another way to say that
generalization gap shrinks with the
trimming error
and for them that was really important
because now they have one generalization
down which covers both noisy and
noiseless setting
and so this
kind of bound uh is sometimes referred
to as optimistic rate and this
terminology is due to dimitri panchenko
who had a bunch of interesting works
related to this phenomenon
okay um then how should we do in our
setting it's like a square loss it's a
regression so the down looks a bit
different
but this is the main result from this
paper by cerebros
and basically what it's saying is that
again it's a generalization bound
whereas a generalization guarantee
string says that training loss goes to
zero and in particular
if you plug into their bound with
training law zero it looks almost like
the same thing we got it's like the
radimac or squared
except that it has like a huge constant
factor of like 10 to the five it also
has log factors
but it you know this year malone does
not recover any of our results
but it does seem to be a kind of the
right form
now a sort of a another way to look at
it
is
well maybe we could actually make the
idea of decomposing the lost work
so maybe what we need to do is we need
to upper bound test loss
by the training law plus the
generalization gap
but uh for some reason maybe we should
take a square root first because there
is no obvious reason why we didn't take
a square root again so let's take a
square root
and
yeah one weird trick and what you can
show is basically that if you had done
it this way the generalization gap
actually does work out so
the the difference between the slurry
test loss and spirit training loss stays
up around by a
guessing waist or is a rather lacquer
complexion so
that's that's basically uh what we do
and this recovers
the uniform convergence of interpolators
when the training loss is zero
um
yeah it's
you know it's very slightly different
from that in the sense that there's a
one plus two of one term so
like if i was doing it this oops
like by doing it this way i should be
careful to introduce some one plus
little of one factors into this
decomposition but essentially it's this
and uh more formally we get a bond that
looks like this so
you know a few different ways to write
it so in the notation more like the
real certain to worry
it's like the same kind of vowel but now
we figured out all the sharp constants
okay again this is only for gaussian
they're bound as for general data but
for gaussian we figured out all the
sharp constants in their bond
and again okay also why do we take a
square root you can kind of think it's a
natural thing because
you know a lot of cases if you have a
square you should also take a square
root
so really this bond is saying that when
you take samples
the distances in the empirical algebraic
they're kind of lower bounded by
distances in the population l2 metric
with this additive term which is the
gaussian wave
and
yeah we actually show something stronger
than this in the paper but
you know that's basically telling you
how does this theory generalize to
non-zero training loss
just another similar plot to before
now i'm keeping the number of features
fixed and number of samples fixed
and i'm varying the regularization so
the training area is going from zero to
not zero
uh this is some benign overfitting
situation um which is why
the population loss is getting close to
the bay's error which is the purple line
but anyway the bound is is kind of
correctly understanding what's going on
here so it more or less tracks the
training loss
and
you know even though
the green curve which is the training
air is varying a lot um this mountain
can work and the entire regime
yeah in the paper we have other plots so
you can get both sides of the double
decent curve uh with this kind of
generation though
okay and uh so that's
yeah
like i said we have a bunch of other
things in this paper um
and yeah so there's the same summaries
before we we were able to make uniform
convergence working gaussian linear
regression models um
of course there's a bunch of interesting
questions like how to for example make
it
work for a model you know that's not
gaussian regression like a deep network
and one question along the line is how
can you make the theory work for
non-gaussian data
and even what is the correct
generalization of juvenile some data
so that's all i want you to think
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
yeah maybe i went over this uh beginning
i didn't put the absolute value in so if
you have the absolute value there it
totally doesn't work and even with that
research doesn't work
second thing is that without the square
roots it's off but it's only off by
some constant factor so the square roots
are kind of
yeah fixing that constant factor
[Music]
yeah
yeah
why
because you would get huge
[Music]
is different because it varies with the
scale of x and y
yeah yeah
that don't involve x and y
but this is the whole key here right
because x and y here are the the losses
right so saying saying that the
differences between now it's a training
area and tests are saying that
differences between air and kickstarter
are uniform are saying that this is a
square root
mean is different in terms of the scale
of the error
right so saying that
the differences of the square root
are
uniform
right that the differences without the
square root scale with the scale of the
errors
that's exactly what's going on
optimistic you know mr greater why you
know why for interpolators you get
tighter
from convergence
it's convergence it scales with the
scale of error which is correct
okay
um
but there's a way to be handled there's
a way to handle that
by changing the variance like if you if
you don't care about the rate radio
conversions
all right let's start the next stop in
you